ماساه الزلزال في سوريا لم تخلو من سجالات
واتهامات بين القوى السياسيه بشان تجاهل
مناطق عديده دمرها الزلزال وقتل وجرح فيها
المئات من سكانها كان فاقد
[موسيقى]
حمايه وكذا ولد كمان يعني مين مجموعه
حوالي 25 شخص فجاه بتهتز الدنيا
تنزل بنايه مثل طابع البسكوت
قصص نقلها المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن
الاهالي هناك وقال ناشطون فيها ان ما خلفه
الزلزال من دمار لم يكن في الحسبان
فقد طال الزلزال احدى وعشرين قريه على طول
خط كامل في ريف حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف
حماه الشماليه تلك المناطق تخضع لسيطره
النظام وميليشيات ايرانيه بقيت اياما
تعاني الماساه دون مساعده تذكر
ابرزها سراقب ابو الظهور والحاضر ومعره
النعمان يقول الاهالي ربما كان النظام
وميليشياته يقصدون تجاهلها بعد ان ظلت
عصيه لنحو سبعه اعوام لكن النظام عزا
الامر لضعف الامكانيات
ايضا قرى في عفرين وخاصه بلده جنديرس التي
تكتظ بمهجرين سوريين وتخضع لسيطره فصائل
المعارضه والجيش التركي لم يصلها احد
فتكفل الاهالي بدفن ضحاياهم الى جانب قرى
بريف جبله والقدموس بريف اللاذقيه تعرضت
للتجاهل ما اضطر قاطنيها الى التصرف
بامكانات محدوده
وتقول منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه ان معظم
القرى التي تم تجاهلها من قبل النظام
والمعارضه تعاني من الفقر وابسط مقومات
الحياه ناهيك عن البنايات التي شيدها
مقاولون وانهارت في اللحظات الاولى من
الزلزال بسبب الغش بمواد البناء